s
le début de la pandémie.
Pas de hausse de taxes, ni
d'impôts pour les contribuables.
Hugo Lavallée.
- Cette présenté dans des
circonstances particulièrees.
- Revenir au déficit 0 prendra
deux ans de plus et ne
surviendra que 2027. La loi sur
l'équilibre budgétaire devra
être modifiée.
- Il faut d'abord vaincre la
pandémie et ensuite viendra le
moment pour l'équilibre
budgétaire.
- Ce chiffre passe à 12,3
milliards. Même chose l'année
d'après, le déficit prévu de 13
milliards ce changement déficit
de 8 000 000 000 1/2. Le budget
ne prévoit pas précisément
comment en parviendra
.- Il y a plusieurs éléments de
prudence ont été ajouté au cadre
financier qui devrait
dépendamment des conditions nous
permettre de faire un peu mieux
.- Le budget de la santé bondit
de 5,8 % cette année et celui de
l'éducation des 4,6 %.
- La santé et l'éducation sont
les priorités du gouvernement du
Québec.
- En injecteurs à 550 millions
dans les soins Denisev domicile
et en augmenterait aussi le taux
du crédit d'impôt pour le
maintien à domicile des années
de 35 à 40 %. Au chapitre de
l'éducation chaque étudiant
inscrit au cégep ou à
l'université à temps pleine
recevra un soutien de 100 $ par
trimestre. Le gouvernement
consacrera 22 millions en cinq
ans pour les femmes victimes de
violences conjugales.
- Si des soms supplémentaires
sont nécessaires nous allons les
allouer.
- Pour les oppositions le report
du à l'équilibre budgétaire
n'est qu'une tactique.
- Les messages implicites et que
si le gouvernement est réélu il
va y avoir des coupures.
- Les capitaines achetés une
bouée trouée comme si le
gouvernement était complètement
déconnecté des questions
sociales et obsédées par
l'économie des années 90.
- Le ministre Girard n'a pas
inclut les transferts en santé
qu'il réclame au gouvernement
fédéral. Par ailleurs ses
prévisions de croissance
économique sont inférieures à
celles du secteu